in this video i will explain the
wilcoxon test to you we will go through
what wilcoxon test is what the
assumptions are and how it is calculated
and at the end i will show you how you
can easily calculate the wilcoxon test
online with datatab and we get started
right now
the wilcoxon test analyzes whether there
is a difference between two dependent
samples or not therefore if you have two
dependent groups you want to test
whether there is a difference between
these two groups then you can use the
wilcoxon test
now you rightly say hey the t test for
dependent samples does the same thing it
also tests whether there's a difference
between two dependent groups
that's correct of course the wilcoxon
test is the non-parametric counterpart
of the t-test for dependent samples the
special thing about wilcoxon test is
that your data do not have to be
normally distributed
to put it simple if your data are
normally distributed you use a
parametric test
in the case of two dependent samples
this is the t-test for dependent samples
if your data is not normally distributed
you use a non-parametric test
in the case of two dependent samples
this would be the wilcoxon test
now of course you could say well then
i'll just always use the wilcoxon test
and i don't even have to check the
normal distribution at the end of this
video i will show you why you should
always use the t-test if it's possible
to do so
first i have a little reminder for you
what dependent samples are
in dependent samples the measured values
are always available in pairs
the pairs result from for example
repeated measures of the same person
but what is the difference now between
the t-test for dependent samples and the
wilcoxon test
the t-test for dependent samples tests
whether there's a difference in means
if we have a dependent sample say we
took a value from each person once in
the morning and once in the evening
then we can calculate the difference
from each pair
so for example we would have 45 minus 34
which equals 11.
the t test for dependent sample now
tests whether these differences differ
from zero or not in the wilcoxon test we
don't use the differences of means
but we form ranks and then we compare
these ranks with each other
3 is the smallest value in terms of
amount it gets rank 1
4
is the second smallest value and it gets
rank 2
6 gets rank 3 and 11 gets rank 4.
we assign a plus to all positive values
and the minus to all negative values
but don't worry we will go through this
slowly and we'll also look at an example
now we go to the assumptions and the
hypotheses
in the wilcoxon test only two dependent
random samples with at least ordinarily
scaled characteristics
need to be present
the variables do not have to satisfy a
distribution curve what should be
mentioned now however is that the
distribution shape of the differences of
the two dependent samples
should be
approximately symmetric
the null hypothesis in the wilcoxon test
is that there is no difference in the
so-called central tendency of the two
samples in the population that is that
there is no difference between the
dependent groups
the alternative hypothesis is that there
is a difference in the central tendency
in the population so we expect that the
two dependent groups are different so
now we finally look at the quite simple
example
let's say you have measured the reaction
time of a small group of people once in
the morning and once in the evening and
you want to know if there is a
difference between morning and evening
in order to do this you measure the
reaction time of seven people in the
morning and in the evening
the measured values are therefore
available now in pairs
and now you want to calculate the
difference between morning and evening
if the difference would be normally
distributed you would use a t-test for
dependent samples
if it is not we would use a wilcoxon
test let's just assume that there is no
normal distribution
and we need to calculate a wilcoxon test
in order to do this the first thing we
do is we form ranks
we look for the smallest value in terms
of amount that is -2 which gets rank 1.
what is the second smallest value that
is 3 which gets rank 2
and so on and so forth until we have
ranked all the values
the next thing is that we look at the
differences and we try to figure out
which difference is positive and which
is a negative one
for the negative differences we simply
add a minus
then we can add up the positive ranks
and the negative ranks
for the positive ranks we get seven plus
two plus three plus four plus six
which is equal to twenty-two
for the negative ranks we get five plus
one which is equal to six
if there is no difference between
morning and evening the positive and
negative ranks should be approximately
equal
therefore the null hypothesis is that
both rank sums are equal but how can we
test this
now we have the sum of ranks and we use
it to calculate the test statistic w
this is simply the minimum value of t
plus and t minus
in our case it is the minimum value of
22 and 6 and therefore the test
statistic w in our case is 6.
now we can further calculate the value
for t or w that we would expect if there
was no difference between morning and
evening in this case we would get a
value of 14.
therefore if there is no difference
between morning and evening we would
actually expect a value for t plus and t
minus of 14 and thus w would also be 14.
further we can calculate the standard
deviation this is given by this to be
fair a little bit complicated formula
once we're finished with that we can now
calculate the set value
the set value is obtained by calculating
w
minus mu
and dividing that by the standard
deviation
so we compare the value that would be
expected if there was no difference with
the value that actually occurred
note that if there are more than 25
cases normal distribution is assumed in
which case we can calculate the set
value using this formula if there are
less than 25 values the critical t value
is read from a table of critical t
values therefore in our case we would
actually use the table now i will show
you how you can easily calculate the
wilcoxon test online
and then i will go into why i should
always prefer the dependent t test to
the wilcoxon test if it's possible in
order to calculate the wilcoxon test
simply go to datadeb.net you will also
find the link in the video description
and you copy your own data into this
table
then you click on this tab and you will
see the names of all your variables that
you copied into the table above
underneath this tab many hypothesis
tests are summarized and datatab
automatically suggests the appropriate
hypothesis test for your data if you now
select morning and evening datadeb
automatically recognizes that it is a
dependent sample and calculates the
dependent t-test but we don't want to
calculate a t-test we want to calculate
the wilcoxon test so we just click here
now datadeb automatically calculates the
wilcoxon test
here we can read the negative and
positive ranks
and here we see the set value and the
p-value if you don't know exactly how
this is interpreted just look at the
summary in words it says that the
morning group had lower values than the
evening group and a wilcoxon test showed
that this difference was not
statistically significant
p equals
0.312 and now we come as promised to the
point why you should always prefer a
parametric test for example the t-test
to a non-parametric test we already
discussed that the wilcoxon test has
fewer requirements than a t-test now of
course the question may be why do i use
parametric tests like the t-test at all
parametric tests usually have a greater
test strength than non-parametric tests
what does that mean
say you have formulated your null
hypothesis for example reactivity is the
same in the morning and in the evening
whether the null hypothesis is rejected
depends among other things
on the difference in responsiveness
and also on the sample size
in a parametric test usually a smaller
difference or a smaller sample is
sufficient to reject the null hypothesis
so if possible always use a parametric
test
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time
you